the jurgen experience but my point is
that
you know that's how the ccp operates
they will
ruin your industry your business for the
slightest
the slightest offense this happened two
weeks ago
with h m and nike and it's because the
business is
tied to china because china does do
business with the nba huge business huge
business
huge business and you think that this is
is it because china enjoys having the
nba
as an entertainment entity
or is it chinese people love the nba
that's what it is
nba is huge in china it's it's also if
you think about it from the nba
perspective that's their growth that's
their future right you know that's their
biggest growing market for everything
from jerseys to
games to you name it uh and with a lot
of sports that's the case too
and with hollywood and with the stock
market and with silicon valley tech
companies
and with american universities all the
sectors of american society
see the chinese economic market as a
huge lore as well they should
and they do edit films to appease the
standards
of the chinese party self-censorship is
part of is the
cost of doing business right but there's
certain things they do like in dr
strange the tibetan master was replaced
by
uh anglo-saxon woman this is my tibetan
face mask and now you will never be this
episode will never be aired
inside mainland china did i just just
now well i think it's probably already
not going to be aired because all the
[ __ ] you said yeah that too
but now this is really this will really
seal it okay
um and good you know what i mean that's
not to say we shouldn't engage the
chinese people
we need exchanges we need to have
business there and this is another
sort of conundrum of the us china
relationship that i try to take a stab
at
my book in my book which is that you
know we have to engage with the chinese
people we have to have we can't decouple
our economies we can't live in two
different
worlds forever it's not going to work
right but we have to find a way to live
with china
and we have to convince the chinese
government to find a way to live with us
in a way that doesn't compromise our
security and our prosperity and our
public health in other words you know
while we want we would love
it's not about regime change it's not
about a cold war these are sort of like
bumper stickers that people throw out to
dissuade people from having an honest
conversation about how to deal
with a chinese communist party that is
becoming increasingly problematic
in ways that affect our lives and what
i'm trying to say is that
you know we have to be clear-eyed that
you know this is not about china or the
chinese people this is about the party
this is the way the party operates do
you think that that uh
so there's that company that was airing
the chinese the nba games they're making
a lot of money off of that they didn't
want to stop airing the
nba games they had to do that because
the party said so when nike
what was it what did h m do they put up
a statement
questioning whether or not the content
they were getting from xinjiang
was made with forced slave labor just
like hey we're going to look into it
for that one statement their entire
business in china was crushed
okay nike same thing for years they
resisted these companies again they're
in a tough position i get it
uh hey uh the cotton that you're sending
us is that
was that picked by forced labor slaves
like are we allowed to ask is it okay
just for that nike's business was uh
destroyed inside china propaganda
campaign also was it destroyed
they they literally create a well they
do boycotts
and again it's not like here where like
you can boycott something but you have
to convince people
there it's like if the government says
there's a boycott there's a boycott
right and then your your your company
can't sell anything in china and that's
40 of your business you're [ __ ] it's a
pretty big incentive right
and none of these companies are powerful
enough to stand up to the ccp on their
own which is why i think
they have to work with the us government
in some sort of way but that's not
really going on because
politicians just want to dunk on the
companies or they want to like criticize
them for not doing the right thing but
there's no positive incentives to say to
the nba hey listen
why don't we you know get together on
this thing and we'll use our diplomatic
pressure and our diplomatic tools
to make sure that american companies and
industries don't get punished by the
party for [ __ ]
like like a tweet but we're not
sophisticated enough in our
discussion of china or in our government
response to china
to actually make that happen but i think
that's basically where we have to go
and which brings up one another
inescapable question which is
if nike's using uh slave labor for their
shoes
why are sneakers so expensive
what's the overhead it's a very good
question
how are sneakers 150 but anyway that's
neither here nor there
what would they cost if you paid people
well exactly
yeah and what's happening is it just
greed massive profit margins
yeah so anyway this is a long way of
saying that the parties
uh uh if to understand china you have to
understand that the party's in control
of everything
and that uh dealing with that is just
the way things are now
and that doesn't mean that we have to
have a cold war or that we have to
decouple from china it just means we
have to figure out a new way
to first try to convince them not to do
the worst things
and then second to protect ourselves if
they insist catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience